شهر ونصف على بدء الاقتتال الداخلي في
السودان ولا جديد حتى الان ورغم الهدن
الموقته لوقف النار لا بوادر لحل نهائي
تلوح في الافق الخاسر الاول والاكبر في
هذا الصراع العسكري هو المواطن السوداني
الذي بات يعاني الامل اثر حاله الشلال
والنقص الكبير في المواد الاساسيه
والخدمات والمساعدات الانسانيه يغدو
المشهد اكثر تعقيدا يوما بعد يوم مع تشابك
خريطه وانتشار وسيطرات كل من قوات الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وتحديدا في العاصمه
الخرطوم اذ يحكم مشاهدينا الجيش السوداني
قبضته على جميع المدن ما عدا بعض المناطق
بدرفور والخرطوم اما في الخرطوم طبعا
فيسيطر على الجزء الاكبر من القياده
العامه كما يسيطر على المناطق العسكريه
المعروفه الموزعه في المدن الثلاث في
ولايه الخرطوم بالاضافه الى منطقه وادي
سيدنا العسكريه
حيث المطار العسكري الذي تم استخدامه
لاجلاء الجاليات الاجنبيه وتتحرك منه طبعا
الطائرات الطائرات المسلحه وسلاح الجو
السوداني في المقابل تسيطر قوات الدعم
السريع على القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم
وعدد من الوزارات بالاضافه لانتشارها في
منطقه بحري وجنوب ايضا الخرطوم وفي
المناطق السكنيه شرق الخرطوم سكان ام
درمان بولايه الخرطوم في السودان ناشد
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بالحفاظ على وقف
اطلاق النار وحقن الدماء كما روى السكان
طبعا البعض من تجاربهم القاسيه اثناء
القتال بين الاطراف السودانيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات